[Musique]
je vous propose mes chers collègues
qu'on commence notre table ronde
alors monsieur le Président de gourmet
comme ça qu'on dit voilà gourmet avec un
y Monsieur le Directeur Général de
vitamine
vitamique tout va bien Monsieur le
Directeur de recherche à l'inrae merci
beaucoup et monsieur je sais pas comment
on dit chef
aux appels chefs ici voilà voilà merci
beaucoup à vous monsieur Marx donc
président aussi de lui dans d'autres
fonctions mais c'est pas pour ça que
vous êtes ici ce matin enfin dans cette
configuration je vous remercie beaucoup
mes chers collègues nous avons le
plaisir ce matin d'accueillir quatre
invités venant d'horizons très
différents l'entrepreneuriat la
gastronomie et la recherche ce qui les
réuni c'est d'avoir directement ou
indirectement quelque chose à nous dire
sur ce qui est appelé la viande in vitro
viande artificielle ou encore viande
cellulaire viande cultivée selon que
l'on soit pour ou contre la dénomination
viande elle-même ne faisant pas
pleinement consensus cette table ronde
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la mission
d'information sur la viande in vitro que
j'ai confié à nos collègues Olivier
Rickman et à Henri caban qui travaille
ensemble sur ce sur ce sujet la mission
rendra ses travaux le 8 mars soit
quelques jours après le Salon de
l'Agriculture pour poser le sujet la
viande in vitro est différente des
alternatives à base de protéines
végétales comme les galettes de soja ou
de pois il s'agit littéralement mais je
parle sous contrôle de voilà des quatre
invités il s'agit littéralement de
cellules animales prélevées soit par
biopsie sur un animal vivant soit dans
un œuf ou un cordon ombilical ces
cellules sont ensuite placées dans un
bioréacteur et sont nourris nourri dans
un milieu de culture à température
physiologique qui contient des
nutriments et dont la composition qui
varie d'une entreprise à l'autre et bien
souvent le secret de fabrication vous
pourrez peut-être tout de même messieurs
nous apporter quelques précisions sans
dévoiler les secrets de fabrication mais
quelques précisions sur les méthodes les
entreprises du secteur avancent des
promesses notamment en termes
d'opportunités économiques d'autonomie
protéique de bien-être animal puisqu'il
n'y a pas d'animal et d'impact
environnemental notre alimentation ces
promesses sont entourées de nombreuses
incertitudes à ce jour car en dehors des
prototypes à ma connaissance il n'existe
pas de produits à l'échelle industrielle
il sera important néanmoins que nous
inviter discutent de la réalité ou non
de ses promesses dans l'hypothèse ou la
production viendrait à se développer et
je pense que voilà c'est l'objectif ce
sujet peut certes paraître lointain
puisque la technologie n'est pas
complètement mature et puisque aucune
demande d'autorisation n'a été déposée
pour l'heure au sein de l'Union
européenne sur le bureau de l'Autorité
européenne de sécurité des aliments
lèvent ça il nous a été néanmoins il
nous semble néanmoins important de
défricher cette question car il semble
que l'on soit progressivement très
approcher le passage du laboratoire au
site industriel exemple récent
l'entreprise américaine upside food a
passé la première étape de
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché aux
États-Unis en novembre 2021 et il se dit
que dans l'Union européenne de premiers
dossier pour être déposé dès cette année
en France pays où la gastronomie et
l'élevage ont un ancrage pur et
séculaire cette innovation suscite bien
sûr des réactions contrastées des
réactions passionnées des réticences
s'expriment tantôt au sujet de la
viabilité de notre élevage tantôt au
titre de la sécurité sanitaire de
l'alimentation le ministre de
l'Agriculture a répété de façon
constante de fortes réserves à l'égard
de cette technologie a soutenu un
amendement dans la loi climat et
résilience interdisant la viande
synthétique dans la restauration
collective publique en même temps BPI
France a accordé sur des fonds européens
une aide à plusieurs entreprises du
secteur dans un contexte de fortes
compétition à l'échelle mondiale pour la
maîtrise de cette technologie et
ailleurs en Europe les Pays-Bas sur fond
de crise de leur modèle agricole ont
fait de l'agriculture cellulaire l'un
des piliers de leur stratégie pour
l'autonomie protéique donc nous allons
vous entendre tous les quatre nous vous
allons commencer par Monsieur Moret
morinforest ou qui est co-fondateur et
président de gourmet start-up charger au
gynopola Évry et qui est dans la
promesse produit et de fabriquer si je
ne me trompe du foie gras de culture
nous entrons ensuite alors vous avez des
gens du Sud-Ouest ici à la soirée très
très prudent voilà monsieur Étienne du
toit et directeur général de vitamines
filiale du groupe Grimaud qui est
spécialisé dans la sélection animale et
l'élevage de volailles c'est un groupe
que nous connaissons bien qui souhaite
fabriquer des cellules de poulet pour
des plats transformés par exemple des
nuggets là aussi si je ne me trompe pas
Monsieur Jean-François hocket et
directeur de recherche à l'unité mix de
recherche sur les herbivores à l'inrae
il a publié de nombreux articles sur la
viande in vitro et sur ses limites et
enfin je laisserai la parole au chef
Thierry Marx dont je précise qu'il
s'exprime en tant que chef étoilé et non
en tant que président de l'uni vous avez
ouvert avec votre associé le chimiste
Rafael Aumont un centre français
d'innovation culinaire à Paris Saclay
qui s'intéresse à l'alimentation de et
là pour l'anecdote cuisiner une poularde
au vin jaune chère
Marie-Christine et Omori pour Thomas
Pesquet dans la station
internationale mais je crois que se
définissant comme flexitarien ou
végétarien Thierry max ne parlera
aujourd'hui plutôt de la végétalisation
de notre alimentation cette table ronde
pourra durer environ 1h30 1h45 puisque
vous savez que nous avons derrière un
autre programme et cela permettra à
Marie-Christine Chauvin qui préside le
groupe d'élevage le groupe d'études
d'élevage et peut-être à notre collègue
Arnaud Bazin qui nous rejoindra
peut-être tout à l'heure qui lui préside
la section ah mais tu es là mais qui est
là donc pardon je croyais que tu n'étais
pas là Arnaud qui préside la section
animale et société puis à nos collègues
de poser leurs questions monsieur
morinforest après c'est trop longue
introduction je vous passe la parole
voilà merci merci est-ce que le micro
marche oui il a l'air de marcher
bonjour tout le monde je suis ravi
d'être là merci beaucoup pour cette
invitation et surtout pour cette
initiative je pense que cette mission
sénatoriale est absolument pionnière au
monde sur la filière émergente de la
viande de culture et pour moi elle
démonte la capacité de la France à se
poser les bonnes questions au bon moment
sur des sujets de premier plan pour
notre pays le contexte c'est quoi c'est
que la demande de protéine animale est
en très forte augmentation partout à
l'échelle mondiale et elle est portée
évidemment par la hausse de la
démographie donc face à l'impératif de
nourrir les êtres humains via des modes
de production de plus en plus économe en
ressources c'est vraiment tout ça
l'enjeu la viande de culture se présente
comme une opportunité et une solution
d'avenir qu'il faut bien sûr explorer et
dont il faut se saisir et c'est le bon
moment c'est cette motivation qui est à
l'origine de la création de notre
société gourmet dont je suis le
co-fondateur et dirigeant donc on a été
créé en 2019 en Île-de-France dans
l'Essonne comme le rappelle madame la
Présidente et qui emploiera plus d'une
centaine de personnes d'ici l'année
prochaine la viande de culture se
développe un pack en France elle est en
train d'arriver sur le marché elle fait
partie déjà de notre alliculture et elle
s'inscrit dans des
l'histoire des innovations agricoles et
culinaires l'heure pour moi n'est donc
pas de se positionner pour ou contre ce
mode de production mais bien en prendre
actes et de se demander quel rôle la
France veut jouer et va jouer de se
demander comment nous pouvons être
acteur et j'ai même jusqu'à dire leader
de cette filière innovante qui apporte
une solution complémentaire aux méthodes
traditionnelles et réponds en partie à
des nouvelles demandes et des nouvelles
attentes de notre société nous avons la
chance de nous saisir du sujet au bon
moment et cette commission pour moi on
est le parfaite la parfaite
démonstration et d'avoir déjà deux
futurs champions nationaux vital mit et
gourmet donc ici présent qui
s'inscrivent dans les territoires et
dans l'écosystème agricole français
notre entreprise est ainsi en train de
développer un premier atelier de
production dans le Val-de-Marne avec la
clé la création d'emplois locaux
qualifiés et la démonstration du
savoir-faire français en matière
d'innovation puisqu'il s'agira et on en
est très fier de l'un des tous premiers
points de production de viande de
culture à l'échelle mondiale
ce sera un site pour nous et c'est aussi
une priorité très importante à souligner
la démonstration de standard de
production des plus exigeants et
soutenir sans attendre le développement
de cette filière émergente c'est
l'opportunité pour la France et l'Europe
d'être véritablement à la manœuvre
justement dans la définition d'un cahier
des charges en terme de qualité des
produits des modes de production de
sécurité alimentaire pardon ou d'impact
environnemental bref c'est en gros agir
plutôt que subir et être leader plutôt
que suiveur la France va donc continuer
de s'emparer du sujet de façon
constructive et proactive comme elle le
fait via cette présente commission car
la viande de culture est une opportunité
économique majeure et de nombreux États
l'ont déjà perçu notamment en Europe ou
par exemple nos voisins néerlandais ont
récemment lancé un plan d'investissement
public important pour accélérer la
création d'une filière nationale et
locale faisons de même en France ce qui
fait la singularité de l'écosystème
agricole français je pense que c'est sa
capacité d'innovation et à la fois la
richesse de ses savoir-faire et leur
complémentarité donc c'est cet esprit
qui nous anime et qu'il faut soutenir
pour renforcer notre souveraineté
alimentaire mais aussi notre capacité
export on verra que c'est aussi
important pour notre pour notre société
et ne pas laisser d'autres tout
simplement innover à notre place la
France a d'ailleurs tout je suis marié
tradition et innovation et
principalement et particulièrement en
matière agricole et culinaire et on a
vraiment toutes les cartes en main
l'excellence de notre écosystème de
recherche le rayonnement de notre
gastronomie et bien entendu la place
centrale de notre agriculture sont en
terreau unique au monde on a toutes les
cartes en main pour créer une filière
française d'excellence dans un esprit
d'ouverture de complémentarité et
surtout faites de collaboration entre
tous les mondes le monde agricole le
monde de la recherche les acteurs
émergents et les pouvoirs publics c'est
à dire toutes les parties prenantes
autour de cette table je vous remercie
très très bien vous nous expliquerez
tout à l'heure comment vous faites si ça
vous ennuie
donc vital mythe bonjour à tous
je tenais à vous dire que je suis très
honoré aussi d'être parmi vous en tant
que citoyen et je suis très heureux que
le Sénat saisis du sujet de la viande de
culture viande cellulaire ou quelque
soit la manière dont vous voulez
l'appeler aujourd'hui parce que la
dénomination n'est pas fixée alors c'est
vrai la viande de cultiver est un sujet
encore méconnu une élévation qui suicide
des interrogations légitimes et j'espère
qu'on pourra y répondre aujourd'hui mais
c'est avant tout une nouvelle source de
protéines animales goûteuse saine
positif pour la santé respectueuse de
l'environnement au sens large et de ce
fait un véritable enjeu stratégique pour
la France son autonomie alimentaire et
sa compétitivité dans les 10 prochaines
années
tu as quelques mots de présentation sur
sur vitalmit et moi même je m'appelle
Étienne Dutoit donc j'ai un parcours qui
m'a conduit de la finance au milieu
agricole où j'ai travaillé pendant 7 ans
au contact des agriculteurs dans le
domaine des biosimulants avant de
m'intéresser à l'agriculture cellulaire
j'ai ensuite cofondé vitamines avec le
groupe Grimaud en 2018 on va dire qu'on
est une histoire très singulière dans
cet univers de la viande de culture car
on est le seul projet directement ici
des filières agricoles traditionnelles
en effet le groupe grimmo est une etif
familiale située en territoire rural
dans les Mauges donc le cœur de métier
de ce groupe et la génétique animale et
la production d'animaux reproducteurs
tout un tas d'espèces canards port la
pin crevette insecte etc et il y a des
crevettes reproductrices
et le groupe grimmo est donc un acteur
historique de l'élevage est parfaitement
conscient des enjeux actuels
compétitivité de nos filières face aux
productions étrangères nouvelles
attentes sociétales et diversification
des régimes alimentaires nouvelle
difficulté liées au pandémie grippe
aviaire pêche porcine africaine et
nouvelles difficultés liées au
réchauffement climatique emploient des
artifications des campagnes ce groupe
c'est d'ailleurs diversifié depuis une
vingtaine d'années dans la biopharmacie
et la bioproduction c'est finalement de
cette branche qui est issue la
technologie et le savoir-faire de
vitamit pour la culture de cellules de
poulet et de canard donc notre objectif
est de proposer une nouvelle gamme de
protéines animales complémentaire aux
filières existantes avec un cahier des
charges extrêmement exigeant sur
l'empreinte environnementale la sécurité
alimentaire et la santé et bien sûr la
qualité et le goût
on s'est bien entendu poser la question
du sens de la viande de culture et de
son positionnement dans la filière pour
moi effectivement la priorité n'est pas
de reproduire la viande à l'identique
absolument un blanc de poulet plus vrai
que nature etc d'autant que la viande
brute est un produit culturel et que
nous sommes nombreux à ne pas vouloir y
renoncer notre vision est celle de la
complémentarité et on oriente nos
travaux vers la production d'un
ingrédient de poulet cultivé avec le
même goût les mêmes apports
nutritionnels que la viande
conventionnelle pour être utilisé dans
toutes les recettes de produits élaborés
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui on a parlé de
nuggets mais plats cuisinés pizza salade
etc les consommateurs demain auront un
nouveau choix possible les produits
issus de l'agriculture cellulaire qui
intégreront un régime alimentaire de
plus en plus diversifié et nous on veut
que ce nouvel choix il soit français au
plus proche de leur exigences en termes
d'empreinte environnementales de
production locale de sécurité de
sécurité alimentaire de santé et
évidemment de goût
on est très fier d'être dans la course
avec les plus gros projets mondiaux en
travaillant à partir d'une technologie
française brevetée et reconnue depuis
une quinzaine d'années on le voit
désormais la viande de culture se
rapproche chaque jour un peu plus de nos
assiettes un premier produit a été
autorisé à Singapour une pré-approbation
a été donnée aux États-Unis les coups de
revient baisse et les échelles de
production augmente donc le moment est
parfaitement choisi pour s'intéresser à
cette thématique avec une question qui
pour moi est centrale quelle place la
France veut-elle occuper dans cette
nouvelle industrie je vous remercie de
votre attention
très bien
merci Monsieur ok je vous ce directeur
je vous laisse la parole pour voir le
point de vue du scientifique
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
je vais être un petit peu technique dans
mon exposé je m'en excuse par avance et
je vous rappelle tout d'abord le
principe de fabrication de ce qu'on
appelle la viande de culture l'idée est
de prélever des cellules des cellules
souches ou des cellules musculaires sur
un animal vivant ou de travailler avec
des lignées cellulaires immortelles dans
tous les cas ces cellules se multiplient
dans un bioréacteur un bioréacteur de
grande taille
c'est cellules sont plongées dans un
milieu de culture et on obtient à la fin
du processus une grande quantité de
fibres musculaires et donc mon exposé va
être sous la forme de question il y a
d'abord des quelques questions éthiques
au départ si le nombre d'animaux
d'élevage doit diminuer en raison du
développement de la viande de culture
que va devenir la biodiversité animale
et qu'en est-il des animaux qui vont
rester
qui vont être prélevés régulièrement
pour fournir des cellules si on utilise
des lignées cellulaires immortelles en
rendant la problématique des OGM en ce
qui concerne le milieu de culture quelle
est sa composition il doit apporter des
hormones des facteurs de croissance
jusqu'à présent la viande de culture
vendue à Singapour contient du sérum de
vos fœtal comment recycler ce milieu de
culture pour diminuer les coûts
en ce qui concerne la multiplication
cellulaire la question de la stabilité
ou de la dérive génétique doit être
opposée et doit être étudiée en face est
un processus consommateur d'énergie
puisqu'il faut porter les incubateurs à
température physiologique
en ce qui concerne le produit final y
a-t-il des résidus éventuelles du milieu
de culture dans ce produit final quelle
est la composition de ce produit final
quelles sont ses qualités sanitaires
nutritionnelles et sensorielles et tous
les scientifique qui ont publié de
nombreux articles indiqués sur cette
diapositive se pose ce genre de
questions il y a une autre question
est-ce que est-ce de la viande non selon
la législation européenne il y a des
avis variables selon les pays pour des
raisons politiques et ou religieuses
l'AFAO préfère parler de celle base full
c'est à dire aliments à base de cellules
les dégâts et les végétariens pensent
que c'est de la viande mais les
consommateurs brésiliens que nous avons
interrogés pensent le contraire et en ce
qui concerne les experts de la viande
ils insistent sur l'idée qu'il y a
autant de différences entre le vin et le
jus de raisin qu'il y a entre la viande
et le muscle puisqu'il y a une étape
importante de maturation c'est à dire de
transformation du muscle en viande qu'il
faut prendre en compte dans ce processus
une autre question est-ce bon pour
l'environnement il est tout à fait vrai
qu'il y a une étude de l'Université
d'Oxford en 2011 qui a répondu oui à
cette question mais depuis il y a
d'autres études qui auront un petit peu
tempéré cette conclusion
par exemple en 2015 il a été dit que
l'impact environnemental est plus élevé
pour la viande de culture que pour la
viande de poulet ou pour d'autres
sources de protéines il y a une plus
grande consommation d'énergie par
rapport à la viande bovine et cet
article a contredit la première étude
quand on regarde les gaz à effet de
serre qui sont produits par ce processus
c'est essentiellement du CO2 qui
s'accumule dans l'atmosphère au bout de
100 de 100-300 ans etc alors que
l'élevage comme chacun sait produit
essentiellement du méthane qui disparaît
plus vite de l'atmosphère un rapport
privé dont qui a été publié en partie
récemment montre que l'impact carbone
varie d'un facteur 5 suivant le type
d'énergie et insiste sur l'air certitude
de ces estimations il y a un autre
article de synthèse qui indique que
finalement il y a beaucoup de d'étapes
qui ont été oubliées pour estimer
l'impact environnemental de la viande de
culture et certains insistent sur
non seulement la production de gaz à
effet de serre l'utilisation des terres
l'utilisation d'eau mais aussi sur les
services écosystémiques rendus par
l'élevage et il faut bien entendu
prendre ses services en considération
dans la comparaison
qu'en pensent les consommateurs là aussi
c'est extrêmement difficile parce qu'on
interroge les consommateurs sur un
produit qui n'existe pas donc finalement
quelque part
les réponses de ces consommateurs ne
sont pas très fiables néanmoins il faut
faire attention comment les questions
sont posées si vous demandez aux
consommateurs est-ce que vous êtes prêt
à goûter la majorité va répondre oui
est-ce que vous êtes prêts en consommer
régulièrement la majorité va répondre
non donc il y a une acceptation sociale
très variable selon de nombreux facteurs
et la plupart des consommateurs dans
leur grande majorité
voudrait que le prix de ce produit soit
inférieur ou égal à celui de la viande
conventionnelle
la majorité des consommateurs pensent
que a priori se produit ne serait ni ça
ni savoureux ni naturelle les
consommateurs sont sensibles à des
arguments individuels sur leur santé sur
le plaisir de manger et bien que les
consommateurs notamment français
s'interrogent sur les problèmes éthiques
et environnementaux de l'élevage cela ne
suffit pas toujours à convaincre puisque
seulement 18 à 26% des mêmes répondants
pensent que la viande de culture est une
solution et c'est proportion et donc
relativement faible
j'insisterai sur l'importance de la
communication et même si c'est pas le
cas de nos deux entreprises ici
présentes le combat anti-élevage reste
une motivation de certains industriels
la dernière question que je voudrais
poser est la suivante pourquoi le
processus de recherche a-t-il été
inversé en tant que chercheur du monde
académique notre façon de travailler et
la suivante quand nous avons une idée
nous écrivons un projet qui est
expertisé si l'expertise est favorable
on obtient un financement et on
communique son résultat
dans l'état actuel des choses
il y a beaucoup de projets sur lesquels
les entreprises communiquent pour
obtenir des financements privés et nous
estimons que nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui d'une expertise collective
transparente par des organismes tiers
indépendants qui doit avoir accès aux
résultats existants des tenues par les
entreprises pour pouvoir se positionner
en attendant le principe de précaution
doit s'appliquer et je conclurai en
disant que nous organisons le prochain
congrès mondial des sciences animales à
Lyon fin août 2023 et il y aura une
session consacrée à ce thème et nous
allons demander nous allons inviter
l'ensemble des chercheurs qui
travaillent sur ce thème à exposer leurs
travaux à Lyon fin juin fin août 2023 je
vous remercie
merci de salles de ambiances sur la
sur les premières prises de
participation on va donc demander
maintenant au chef Thierry Marx sa
position enfin sa position en tout cas
c'est réflexions voilà
on n'a pas beaucoup de recul alors je
suis là parce que évidemment je suis
chef étoilé vous me connaissez peut-être
ce titre là mais on a Paris Saclay un
centre de recherche et développement qui
s'appelle le cefik avec Raphaël au mont
et évidemment on est curieux de
l'alimentation du futur et on a regardé
un petit peu dans le détail avec le peu
de recul que que nous avons sur ce type
de produit pour moi j'ai du mal à
appeler sa viande
mon sujet il est de pas tout mélanger
c'est-à-dire que gastronomie dans une
dans la gastronomie vous mangez une
histoire une relation à l'humain une
relation un terroir etc dans
l'alimentation c'est plus compliqué
c'est à dire que on entrevoit dans ce
type de pratique encore quelque chose
d'ultra transformé pour les plus
modestes dans un pays où déjà on a une
fracture alimentaire au-delà d'avoir une
fracture sociale et bien c'est compliqué
c'est encore de l'ultra transformer pour
les plus modestes qui sont éloignés d'un
reste à vivre alimentaire suffisant donc
ça nous inquiète un petit peu parce que
là il y a pas de goût le peu qu'on est
goûté et notamment sur les Nuggets et
bien il a fallu pour leur donner une
saveur et une texture les aromatiser on
sait comment l'industrie aromatise tout
ça et
se restaurer c'est pas ça c'est vraiment
ramener dans l'assiette une histoire un
savoir manger un savoir-être autour de
la table la table et l'alimentation
c'est plaisir bien-être santé encore une
fois j'entrevois là
l'industrie agroalimentaire qui se dit
bingo on va encore rentrer dans la
théorie du low cost du tout pas cher
pour les plus modestes et ça ça nous
inquiète un petit peu on est curieux on
n'est pas critique à Paris Saclay on
regarde un petit peu ce qu'est
l'alimentation du futur mais on voudrait
pas laisser croire que la science et la
technologie pourraient répondre
simplement à l'impact environnemental et
un impact social la protéine animale
elle est surconsommer sur cette planète
on en mange dans de les conditions parce
que on a cru à la théorie du low cost du
tout pas cher et ça c'était une mauvaise
théorie parce que dans le tout pas cher
on a sur fabriqué de la protéine animale
et on a eu un impact sur l'environnement
qui était détestable mais aujourd'hui si
on ramène dans le flexitarisme 80/20 80
% du végétal 20%
protéines animales on peut s'apercevoir
que dans 20 ans on pourrait ramener à
quelques équilibres c'est notre
réflexion on n'est pas critique on n'est
pas arbitre non plus quand on prend la
casquette de Paris Saclay et bien on se
dit bah regardons pas de conflit entre
traditions et innovation avançons si ça
peut améliorer le sort de la planète et
surtout le sort du genre humain mais
avec beaucoup de précautions surtout
que à chaque fois qu'on veut nous vendre
ce type de produit on nous met en avant
l'impact environnemental et ça c'est un
peu gênant quand je vois ce qu'il faut
en termes d'énergie pour produire ce
type de ce qu'on appellerait de la
viande j'ai pas assez de recul pour en
tant qu'artisan et en tant que chercheur
là-dessus merci
Olivier puis Henri Cabanel lyrics
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues quand j'ai proposé à la
présidente prima de monter une audition
sur le sujet de la viande in vitro je ne
savais pas encore que cela se
transformerait en mission d'information
j'avais en revanche quelques idées
arrêtées je dirais plutôt réserver à
l'égard de cette innovation et au fil de
la quarantaine d'auditions que nous
avons menées je peux dire que mon regard
a quelques peu évolué sur la question il
reste que j'ai encore plusieurs
interrogations et mon corps rapporteur
Henri Cabanel exprimera bien ses doutes
qui sont loin d'être tous levés mais
force est de reconnaître que la France
fait partie du marché unique et que
l'autorisation dans le cadre de la
procédure nouveaux aliments sera donné
au niveau européen et non français
dans ces conditions la question des
probablement pas tant de savoir si le
produit doit être autorisé ou non en
France la réponse ne dépend pas vraiment
de nous Français en tout cas pas de nous
en tant que parlementaire la question
est plus de savoir un peu à la manière
des OGM même si le sujet est différent
si nous essayons de prendre une petite
part dans la compétition mondiale ou si
nous laissons les autres le faire à
notre place et arriver sur notre marché
sans que nous ne maîtrisons la
technologie les autres ce sont notamment
les États-Unis Israël et les Pays-Bas
j'étais justement ce lundi au Pays-Bas
pour aller à la rencontre de deux des
principales entreprises développant ce
produit en Europe nos amis à Maastricht
et mitable adept à côté de La Haye j'ai
aussi eu l'opportunité de rencontrer le
ministère de l'Agriculture néerlandais
et je vous donne je dois dire que j'ai
été frappé par la différence d'approche
là-bas un plan public de 60 millions
d'euros a été débloqué pour venir en
soutien à la recherche dans ce domaine
je ne dis pas nécessairement que nous
devions suivre leur exemple la France et
la France les Pays-Bas sont les Pays-Bas
avec un attrait plus marqué pour
l'innovation et des contraintes en
termes de surface agricole utile et une
agriculture très intensive ayant
d'ailleurs causé de graves pollutions à
l'azote et désormais une crise agricole
majeure mais tout de même cela interroge
d'autant qu'il n'y a pas que la viande
in vitro il y a tout un champ de R&D
comprenant aussi la fermentation de
précision que l'on sent frémissant
j'aurais donc deux questions
que pouvez-vous nous dire d'abord sur la
question de la complémentarité ou de la
substitution avec les activités
agricoles et notamment l'élevage dans
les hypothèses les plus optimistes il
semble que la viande de culture
représenterait seulement
0,08% du marché mondial de la viande à
l'horizon 2027 2030 cela semble peu mais
si la progression est exponentielle
c'est déjà significative des recherches
sur la production de viande in vitro à
la ferme sont actuellement menées vous
semble-t-il crédible ou s'agit-il au
contraire de pures opérations de
communication par ailleurs dans quelle
mesure la viande cultivée pourrait-elle
s'insérer selon vous dans l’écosystème
agricole et agroalimentaire existant je
pense tant à l'amont avec les nutriments
nécessaires au milieu de culture car
Laval avec l'insertion ou non dans notre
industrie agroalimentaire ou notre
cuisine enfin j'aurai une dernière
question sur la gamme recherchée on
entend parfois que le coût fait obstacle
à ce que le produit soit accessible pour
les ménage modestes ou pour les pays en
développement
au contraire insistent sur l'intérêt du
produit pour remplacer la viande de
mauvaise qualité importé de l'autre bout
du monde et pour satisfaire la
croissance de la demande en protéines
animales par exemple la Chine qu'en
est-il selon vous merci
très bien Henri oui merci madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues
je vous remercie messieurs pour vos
exposés je réponds ma part aussi deux
questions la première que je partage
avec Olivier Redman portent sur la
question de l'appellation de votre
produit de vos procédés qui ont le voit
suscite beaucoup de débats d'ailleurs le
chef Marc Sana en a parlé
de ce que je comprends il faut
distinguer trois aspects premièrement la
terme générique viande en tant que tel
que nous banalisons tous par commodité
de langage mais qui peut être discuté
car il me semble que nous n'en sommes
pas encore à reproduire des côtes de
boeuf ou même des pièces texturées avec
des cellules musculaires de gras de Sein
et de tissus conjonctifs
pour autant les végétariens ne
consommeraient pas de votre produit qui
reste un produit origine animale
deuxièmement le nom de l'espèce en
elle-même dont on comprend qu'il serait
difficile de se passer pour
l'information du consommateur au regard
notamment des allergènes
troisièmement la forme du produit steak
saucisse carpaccio lardons etc cela nous
renvoie un débat que nous avons connu
avec des alternatives à base de
protéines végétales l'utilisation de ces
termes a été interdite par la loi pour
des produits non animaux mais le décret
d'application a été suspendu pour des
raisons de forme et on peut imaginer
assez facilement les contournements
on comprend que ces termes soient
intéressant pour vos perspectives
commerciales et pour l'acceptabilité des
consommateurs mais elles sont aussi
frais dans notre acceptabilité sociétale
car on voit que le monde agricole se
braque à cause de votre utilisation de
ces termes pourrait-on envisager
d'autres termes que celui de viande dans
ces hypothèses à quel autre possibilité
d'appellation commerciale pourrez-vous
recourir ma seconde interrogation porte
sur l'impact que pourrait avoir votre
technologie sur la concentration du
marché de la viande c'est d'ailleurs
l'un des arguments qu'emploie monsieur
PHENO notre ministre pour exprimer ses
réserves il ne veut pas dit-il de
mastodonte de la viande dans l'hypothèse
de ces technologies ou cette technologie
se déploierait à grande échelle on peut
imaginer une concentration très forte
dans ce secteur dont l'amant était
jusqu'ici relativement décentralisée du
moins en France on voit d'ailleurs que
les géants américains européens de la
viande comme Bellegarde JBS ou Tyson se
positionne en investisseur n'oublions
pas que dans un contexte de
mondialisation alimentaire des produits
développés d'un des pays riches peut
avoir des conséquences importantes chez
nous mais aussi à notre bout du monde
certaines entreprises comme mozamites
disent vouloir un modèle décentralisé
mais pour aller au-delà de la bonne
volonté affichée des entreprises quelle
garde-fous peut-on imaginer par exemple
en termes de propriété intellectuelle
pour limiter la concentration de ce
secteur et surtout le coût de production
de la biennique vitro pourrait-il
vraiment baisser sans économie d'échelle
Siri de questions plus exactement
peut-être monsieur borinforest voulait
apporter quelques éléments de réponse
sur ces questions
alors elles sont très vastes peut-être
commencer par les dernières sur la sur
l'appellation
effectivement vous l'avez dit en
préambule on utilise communiquement le
mot viande de culture plutôt par
commodité il faut juste se rappeler que
les recommandations d'étiquetage seront
tranchées dans le cadre des procédures
de mise sur le marché d'approbation
réglementaire notamment à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne donc le dernier mot
ne reviendra ni aux entreprises il
reviendra peut-être dans le cours des
choses au final au consommateurs qui
aujourd'hui comme les différentes
alternatives protéiques par commodité
utilise des mots dérivés des produits
animaux pour les appeler
ça c'est le premier élément de réponse
je pense que comme vous l'avez bien
rappelé il y a trois niveaux le mot
viande c'est pas quelque chose sur
lequel évidemment nous en tant que
société gourmet on est on est cramponné
comme vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Présidente on travaille sur une
alternative au foie gras déjà qui est en
lui-même une appellation réglementée
qu'on utilisera bien évidemment pas dans
nos étiquetages de produits on pourra
peut-être y faire référence car il
s'agit d'une alternative mais dans aucun
cas notre produit ne pourra s'appeler
foie gras et on en est conscient et on
accepte complètement cette contrainte
maintenant le l'expérience aussi
gustative de notre produit qui que je
rappelle et pour revenir sur les propos
de Monsieur Marx pour nous s'inscrit
dans une forme de savoir-faire dans une
forme de nouvelle tradition en cours de
construction a été développé avec des
chefs avec des personnalités du monde
culinaire dans le cadre de nos
développements de produits et qui ont
quelque part aussi reconnu des
propriétés sensorielles proches du
foiler et de fait à défaut de mieux
c'est compliqué d'imaginer une autre une
autre une autre appellation à court
terme qu'on n'utilisera pas sur nos
produits mais par commodité quand on
fait référence à nos produits c'est
celle-ci qu'on utilise
l'allergie vous l'avez rappelé c'est
fondamental vu que nos cellules elles
partent d'un prélèvement animal que le
consommateur sache qu'il consomme du
poulet de la crevette du canard du bœuf
car originellement il s'agit de
véritables matières animales même si
elle a été
d'une façon nouvelle
on parle beaucoup d'énergie à la
crevette par exemple c'est fondamental
de savoir sur l'étiquetage que on achète
un produit fait de fête crevette
la place de la filière je vais un petit
peu vite pour revenir sur toutes ces
questions
l'intégration de la viande de culture au
sein de la de la filière plus générale
pour moi elle est évidente sur la partie
amont car il faut bien situer la méthode
de production qui consiste à alimenter
des cellules avec des nutriments qui
sont les plus qui sont identiques aux
nutriments consommés par les animaux
sous une autre forme un animal va
consommer des tourteaux par exemple des
tourteaux de maïs des tourteaux de soja
les cellules vont consommer les mêmes
nutriments qu'on peut retrouver dans ces
tourteau évidemment sous forme
différente puisque les cellules n'ont
pas la capacité de mastiquer de digérer
les nutriments sous ce format là mais il
s'agit de la même source d'origine
agricole donc il y a une opportunité non
seulement pour développer une filière de
production de protéines en France mais
également d'intégrer le monde agricole
pour la fourniture de ce qu'on appelle
le milieu de culture qui est le
l'alimentation des cellules et là des
des perspectives d'économie circulaire
sont fondamentales car on pourrait
imaginer recycler
des matériaux agricoles non valorisés
qui pourraient devenir des nutriments
extrêmement intéressants pour les
cellules parce qu'il y a une plus grande
flexibilité sur l'acceptation des
cellules par rapport aux animaux qui ont
des contraintes justement liées à leur
système digestif je vais peut-être
laisser la parole sur d'autres questions
à Étienne si tu veux compléter il y a
beaucoup de choses
il y a beaucoup de choses effectivement
je te rejoint sur un certain nombre de
points
un point qui n'a pas été abordé c'est
effectivement les questions de propriété
intellectuelle de technologie etc
effectivement on est sur un domaine
complètement nouveau on est sur une
véritable innovation et d'où
effectivement la nécessité comme ça a
été rappelé de développer une recherche
publique en France sur le sujet et
d'avoir des entreprises qui développent
leur propre technologie pour ne pas être
dépendant de technologie qui viendrait
de l'étranger et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on voit des investissements
très importants dans certains pays les
États-Unis Israël la Hollande on dispose
également ici de technologie et je pense
que c'est important dans cette
perspective long terme faut remettre les
choses en perspective en disant mais
qu'est-ce que ça sera nos consommateurs
nos moments de consommation d'endices ou
15 ans de disposer deux technologies
françaises pour tout simplement être
autonome et proposer nos propres
produits au marché français donc il y a
un enjeu là-dessus et c'est aussi pour
ça qu'on est là aujourd'hui voilà pour
pour vous mettre voilà dans la boucle et
inciter à développer des technologies
propriétaires françaises
et d'ailleurs pour compléter les parmi
les
thématiques d'investissement des
Pays-Bas dont on a parlé du plan
d'investissement public pour développer
cette filière il y a une partie des 60
millions d'euros qui iront dans la
construction de plateformes de recherche
publique qui générale du coup de la
propriété intellectuelle qui est
générale des données scientifiques en
accès libre qui pourra bénéficier à la
fois mon académique mais également aussi
aux entreprises qui veulent se lancer
pour quelque part aller aussi plus vite
et ça c'est fondamental de le faire
également en France il faut que le
milieu académique est de recherche
s'empare également du sujet bien sûr
Monsieur le Directeur oui je suis tout à
fait d'accord sur la question des
nutriments
il y a une différence évidente entre
aliments et nutriments mais vous savez
bien sûr que les nutriments qui réjuste
qui résultent de la digestion des
aliments dépendent en grande partie
de la population microbienne qui a dans
le tube digestif et c'est très différent
par exemple entre un ruminant qui va
consommer de l'herbe et un monogastrique
et même au sein d'une même espèce le
profil des nutriments qui résulte de la
digestion va évoluer en fonction du
régime alimentaire par exemple donc
c'est quelque chose de très compliqué de
reproduire l'ensemble des nutriments
qu'on va mettre dans le milieu de
culture
et j'ai une autre question au-delà de
cette complexité c'est comment les
produire avec quelle méthodologie ça
suppose certainement comment des unités
de production en amont et par ailleurs
c'est pas les nutriments qui me posent
le plus de questions c'est la question
des hormones et des factures de
croissance qu'il faut mettre dans le
milieu de culture pour que les cellules
se multiplient
voilà quelques éléments et il y avait un
autre point que que je voulais aborder
concernant la recherche publique
comme nous sommes effectivement
interrogés notamment par la presse sur
ce sujet là nous avons effectivement
développé des travaux dans le domaine de
la recherche publique mais avec une
stratégie qui est qui est différente
c'est-à-dire que a priori comme vous
êtes en avance sur le plan technique on
n'a pas vocation à reproduire les
travaux que vous avez fait on a plutôt
vocations à
étudier ce cette problématique dans sa
globalité la globalité d'acceptation
sociale l'impact environnemental etc
les aspects techniques étant simplement
un aspect du problème et pour avancer
sur ces aspects techniques c'est vrai
que
il faut évidemment partager des données
ou partager des résultats pour que comme
le rappeler tout à l'heure c'est
résultat soient expertisé contre
expertisé par différents laboratoires de
recherche dans le monde afin d'apporter
un éclairage complémentaire sur les
travaux qui sont faits jusqu'à présent
non non mais
je suis saisi un peu par le propos et on
parle depuis un moment de viande et ça
fait quelques années qu'on nous parle de
viande et il y a été évoqué le sourcing
de ces produits et finalement tôt tard
ça va finir par nous échapper ce
sourcing et dans ce mot viande moi je
pense qu'il y a déjà un trompe l'oeil
presque une tromperie et qu'on va vers
une industrialisation massive de
l'alimentation donc un appauvrissement
encore plus fort
un papillon culturel quand j'entends
parler de foie grasses à une histoire
quelques années on a massifié la
production de foie gras et finalement le
foie gras est devenu un produit assez
banal et on continue là-dedans pour
encore plus de revenus plus
d'industrialisation plus
d'appauvrissement culturel et c'est ce
qui m'inquiète un petit peu dans ces
dans ces travaux parce que ça
pourrissement culturel conduit à ne plus
pouvoir à un moment donné permettre de
revenir à une idée assez gastronomique
plaisir bien-être santé que doit être
l'assiette et un moment donné quand on
veut répondre et j'entends les enjeux
pour pas que la France soit à la traîne
mais finalement la France n'a plus le
pouvoir de dire ça stop non on en veut
pas chez nous donc à moi ça me gêne un
petit peu en tant qu'artisan maintenant
en tant que chercheur j'écoute le propos
mais je n'arrive pas à me déconnecter de
cette idée de déjà de vouloir massifier
encore plus l'industrialisation de notre
nourriture et donc de cette
mondialisation et de cette
approvérissement culturel encore une
fois on ramène tout sur la consommation
et sur le prix pas assez sur la culture
savoir manger c'est savoir être c'est
redonner du sens à son alimentation se
restaurer c'est quelque chose qui veut
dire quelque chose en termes de lien
social on l'oublie c'est c'est très
important sinon on peut effectivement se
nourrir comme à la Pitié-Salpêtrière
avec une perfusion
et j'ai pas de problème donc de m'amener
dans l'idée dans l'idée de fantasmer que
ce serait un pseudo foie gras une pseudo
viande donc je n'ai même plus le pouvoir
du sourcing du produit j'ai un peu de
mal avec ça par contre j'entends le
propos de dire il faut que la France ne
soit pas à la traîne de la recherche et
ce qu'on sache pourquoi on en veut et
pourquoi on en veut pas et ça ça me
paraît intéressant de ramener aussi
cette discussion sur le social et que
l'agriculture est là du sens et un sens
social et culturel et là on part encore
dans ce que j'entendais dans ce que je
lisais sur les 70 sur cette théorie du
low cost sur du tout pas cher renoncé à
la qualité en échange pas on fera manger
pas cher et on vous laisse à croire en
fonction de ça que vous avez du pouvoir
d'achat c'est une manipulation des
masses moi qui me gêne pardon de parler
comme ça
alors Monsieur duthove à droite non mais
juste pour rebondir sur le côté
appauvrissement culturel qu'on s'entende
bien on n'est pas là pour remplacer la
viande on est là on nous ce qu'on
propose c'est un nouveau choix pour le
consommateur qui aujourd'hui diversifie
ces sources de protéines c'est déjà une
réalité ça consommation de viande
diminue plus de végétal demain des
insectes point d'interrogation
intégrer et là c'est un nouveau choix un
nouveau type de protéines animales si le
si le terme viande vous vous questionne
et c'est complètement compréhensible
donc il y a pas d'appauvrissement quand
on propose un nouveau choix le deuxième
chose c'est sur la qualité des denrées
alimentaires qu'on va manger aujourd'hui
il y a une injonction et vous l'avez
rappelé qui est un petit peu paradoxale
où on demande à nos agriculteurs
d'évoluer vers plus d'agroécologie plus
de qualité et en même temps de maintenir
des prix extrêmement bas et si possible
d'augmenter la production parce que la
France n'est pas autonome en protéines
moi j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'il y a
une complémentarité entre les solutions
dites technologique qu'on propose
aujourd'hui pour accompagner une
agriculture qui est dans une transition
et qui évolue très favorablement en
France vers plus d'agroécologie ce qui
ne va pas faire exploser les rendements
il faut quand même avoir le courage de
le dire et qu'au contraire c'est
complémentaire de développer d'une part
une agriculture
agroécologique de qualité pour tous et
d'autre part en complément dans un
régime alimentaire diversifié d'autres
solutions d'autres produits qui sont
également de qualité
à la fois au niveau du goût à la fois à
la fois d'un point de vue santé et d'un
point de vue nutritionnel pour une
nutrition globale
et bien alors je vais laisser la parole
à la présidente du groupe d'études
élevage voilà et ensuite Arnaud Bazin
président de animal et société merci
présidente mes chers collègues messieurs
merci pour vos interventions voilà je
voulais moi revenir sur le soutien de la
viande in vitro parmi lesquels on peut
trouver des stars et des grandes
fortunes de l'acide Nikon Valley qui
finance le développement de ce produit
or certaines de ces fortunes ont pu
financer aussi des associations que l'on
peut qualifier d'animalisme mon idée
n'est pas de dire que ces associations
sont financées pour préparer le terrain
car je comprends bien que la viande in
vitro est développée par des entreprises
y compris dans le secteur de la viande
distinctes de ces associations je ne dis
pas que c'est votre cas messieurs mais
toutefois je souhaiterais savoir si cela
ne vous met pas mal à l'aise de
prospérer sur une forme de dénigrement
de l'élevage qui est réduit à son seul
impact environnemental et en termes de
bien-être animal
l'explication scientifique est très très
éclairante et je vous remercie monsieur
le directeur car moi mes réflexions j'ai
l'habitude de les appuyer sur du
scientifique n'oublie pas un peu vite
les aspects positifs de l'élevage qui
est d'abord de nourrir le pays et aussi
pour ces retombées économiques dans la
ruralité et également dans nos paysages
et c'est également la survie de la
biodiversité de nos paysages le pâturage
y participent ne va-t-on pas vers la
disparition de certaines races d'animaux
si ce produit venait à se développer à
très très grande échelle qu'adieu
aimerait-il de nos fromages AOP et
excusez-moi je pense tout
particulièrement au comté qui est le
fromage de chez moi qui a été reconnu le
meilleur fromage du monde l'année
dernière
ça suffit
j'ai le droit d'être chauve
par ailleurs vous dites que votre
produit à vocation a remplacé le poulet
brésilien aux médicaments la réalité
économique de notre élevage aujourd'hui
c'est que l'élevage de qualité est
prépondérant en France qui les fragile
économiquement et ce n'est pas l'élevage
intensif que nous trouvons par ailleurs
dans le monde comme par exemple en Chine
aux États-Unis la viande in vitro n'est
peut-être pas la principale menace qui
place qui plane excusez-moi sur notre
élevage aujourd'hui mais il est vrai que
notre élevage n'avait vraiment pas
besoin de ceci
Arnaud je sais pas s'il y aura des
réponses à ça mais Arnaud Arnaud bazar
merci madame la Présidente et merci
d'avoir organisé cette table ronde où
j'ai entendu des choses déjà forte
intéressantes parce que je venais avec
certaines questions mais je vais y
revenir certaines ont des débuts de
réponse pour votre information notre
collègue vétérinaire aussi dans la vie
antérieure
donc une remarque générale et trois
questions la remarque générale c'est que
évidemment on s'intéresse ce matin à
cette entre guillemets viande de culture
mais je pense qu'il faudra jamais perdre
de vue de place et ce débat dans une
perspective plus large de d'apport
protéique pour l'alimentation humaine
parce qu'il y a aussi les protéines
végétales on en a dit un mot il y a la
fermentation de précision c'est le terme
a été employé aussi tout à l'heure
peut-être c'est assez mal connu moins
bien connu mais ça à mon avis c'est une
technique d'intérêt aussi et de
recherche et d'innovation donc dans un
schéma général d'alimentation qu'on peut
très difficilement modifier parce que
c'est des c'est des choses qu'on reçoit
avec notre éducation dès la petite
enfance il y a quand même à préciser
vers quel modèle on va est-ce que on a
un modèle qui ne va pas évoluer et celui
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui avec une
partie tradition une partie entre
guillemets industrialisation ou est-ce
qu'on va petit à petit évoluer vers des
apports protéiques plus végétaux avec
peut-être des éléments de fermentation
de précision pas pour nos pays mais pour
des pays moins favorisés toute cette
question là mon avis elle mérite quand
même d'être vu globalement ensuite sur
les trois questions que je me posais la
première question c'est et par
hiérarchie évidente d'importance
première question c'est la question
sanitaire et elle a été évoquée par le
représentant de l'INRA et tout à l'heure
on prend des cellules souches
pluripotante il faut qu'elle se
différencie en cellule alors deux fois
pour faire du foie gras deux muscles
pour faire du muscle de ou du muscle de
poulet comme ça a été également évoqué
et pour ça il faut leur donner un milieu
de culture dans lequel il peut y avoir
en effet des hormones des peptides
diverses et variées des intrants
qu'aujourd'hui moi je ne connais pas
donc c'est ces éléments là ils devront
être pris en compte pour un éventuel
agrément il faut qu'on ait une garantie
de sécurité sanitaire
liée au milieu de culture on peut
espérer avec la rigueur des différentes
des processus qu'on règle d'autres
problèmes sanitaires qu'on a avec les
produits traditionnels comme la
contamination par des bactéries on en a
malheureusement des exemples de temps en
temps mais on se pose la question des
intrants qu'est-ce qu'il y a
qu'est-ce qu'on utilise vraiment pour
ces différenciations et ces
multiplications à part évidemment les
nutriments dont on a posé le cadre tout
à l'heure et comment tout ça va-t-il
être pris en compte dans la démarche
d'agrément au niveau européen je l'ai
entendu mais moi j'aimerais bien être
éclairé sur toutes ces questions là
parce que si il faut quand même que la
garantie sanitaire soit assurée la
deuxième question c'était le bilan
environnemental au sens large il y a pas
seulement les gaz à effet de serre les
effluents etc là j'ai compris que
aujourd'hui on peut pas faire notre Dion
parce qu'il y a du pot il y a du contre
donc il est tout à fait urgent qu'on ait
des éléments complémentaires là-dessus
des études globales alors vous me direz
sur des processus des processus
industriels qui n'existent pas
aujourd'hui mais qui va falloir essayer
de se projeter quand même pour avoir au
moins une première approche une
approximation
et la troisième question mais ça elle
trouvera sa réponse je dirais quasi
naturellement c'est la question
économique est-ce que c'est viable
économiquement c'est la question que je
me pose depuis le début maintenant moi
je n'ai pas participé à la levée de
fonds de fond pour les startups donc je
suis pas très inquiet à titre personnel
mais je vois qu'il y a beaucoup d'argent
qui s'investit là-dedans donc il faudra
quand même que cette question économique
avec
l'éventualité d'y mettre d'ailleurs de
l'argent public en termes de recherche
on est à une première approche parce que
on va pas non plus investir à fond perdu
et puis ma conclusion provisoire très
provisoire je rejoins là dessus
Marie-Christine Chauvin c'est qu'on a
absolument besoin d'une démarche
scientifique
en dehors de tous les aspects polémiques
qui peut être qui peuvent polluer le
débat une démarche scientifique en effet
pour savoir si sanitairement il n'y a
pas de problème pour savoir si en terme
d'environnement le bilan est positif ou
pas après tout le reste c'est
consommateurs qui tranchera et
l'économique globale qui tranchera mais
pour ça en effet et c'est très
intéressant de le voir qu'on a eu un
processus de recherche inversé c'est une
originalité maintenant je pense qu'il
n'est pas trop tard pour bien faire et
que il est plus que temps que en effet
des tiers indépendants et sachant sur la
sur ces questions là soit mobilisées ça
peut être que de la recherche publique
avec éventuellement d'autres apports
mais pour ça il faut qu'il y ait des
initiatives
de l'administration je vais pouvoir
politique pour que on puisse rapidement
y voir clair là-dessus merci merci je
vais on va prendre toutes les questions
des unes derrière les autres donc voilà
Franck montoget merci madame la
Présidente merci à vous
merci à vous quatre pour vous
interventions
je voudrais revenir sur le mot culture
du de l'appellation vient de culture
voilà moi je pense que la la nourriture
le rapport la nourriture l'histoire que
Monsieur Marx a évoqué c'est aussi un
trait de civilisation
le foie gras je suis un pays d'un pays
de foie gras je suis très très attaché
vous en doutez tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
le foie gras de l'Égypte ancienne parce
que parce que ça remonte à très très
longtemps n'est pas le foie gras
d'aujourd'hui mais avec ce que vous nous
proposez on est fondamentalement dans un
changement de paradigme
de rapport
civilisationnels différents complètement
différents à la nourriture voilà je vais
pas appeler à la rescousse Claude de
lévisch 3 sur cette question-là qui a
écrit beaucoup de choses très très
intéressantes mais c'est exactement ça
auquel on est on est comme confronté
donc
ce sujet votre sujet illustre aussi pour
moi la question de l'évolution du modèle
agricole de l'agriculture et de la place
qu'à l'agriculteur producteur dans ce
processus avec ce que vous nous proposez
qui est en fait une industrie voilà
agroalimentaire on s'éloigne du modèle
que l'on connaît aussi sur nos
territoires pour aller une fois de plus
vers les agriculteurs producteurs
exécutant au service d'entreprise en
l'occurrence agro agroalimentaire voilà
donc c'est c'est vraiment
illustratif d'un choix de civilisation
qui n'est pas le mien voilà je vous le
dis clairement et je me crois parce que
j'essaie aussi de fonner mes analyses et
mes positions sur des données objectives
le plus possible je pense que comme le
monsieur de l'INRA lindraule l'a dit il
faut absolument qu'on avance sur le le
processus et qu'on objective
effectivement toutes les données de ce
de ce problème de cette question là avec
si possible notamment sur la question
environnementale et climatique des
études d'impact complètes et pas biaisé
comme on les a aujourd'hui moi quand
j'ai entendu que l'élevage doit être
complètement éradiquée parce que il
réchauffe l'atmosphère etc c'est un des
aspects de l'élevage mais c'est pas le
seul voilà il y a aussi des impacts en
termes de de séquestration de carbone
enfin je rentre pas dans le détail voilà
on a besoin on a besoin aussi le citoyen
a besoin de tout ça pour se faire une
idée et je termine sur un point
fondamental et là je rejoins
complètement les propos de Monsieur Marx
la question de l'accessibilité en termes
de coûts des Français de nos concitoyens
les plus modestes aux protéines et à la
viande et à une viande de qualité voilà
et ça ça pose la question du pouvoir
d'achat qui est qui est évidemment lié
au problème
dans son ensemble merci
Bernard buis merci présidente merci pour
vos propos donc deux questions la
première sur l'impact environnemental de
la vie en in vitro l'agriculture
aujourd'hui est en pleine période de
transition afin de limiter son impact en
carbone cela étant quels sont les
données actuelles sur l'impact
énergétique de la production de viande
in vitro un tel mode de production
Consulting moins d'énergie que l'élevage
traditionnel ou s'agit-il au contraire
d'une fausse bonne idée qui serait
contente productive dans la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique et puis une
question concernant les conséquences
d'un tel mode de production quelques
jours avant le lancement du Salon de
l'Agriculture on peut s'interroger sur
les conséquences d'un tel mode de
production la viande in vitro en
laboratoire engendrerait-elle pas un
recul de l'élevage paysan dans notre
pays par ailleurs quelles seraient les
conséquences sur la gestion des paysages
et des prairies enfin que penser du
risque d'accaparent de l'alimentation
par quelques films firmes qui pourraient
demain de tenir un pouvoir considérable
question presque philosophique Laurent
Duplomb attention ça va déménager
là
je veux nier être objectif ni faire de
la philosophie je veux simplement me
rappeler de ma jeunesse ou dans les
années 70-80 on nous expliquait qu'après
là on est 2000 nous mangeons tous des
cachets ou des
cachets je crois et que l'alimentation
ne saurait plus un plaisir
depuis 2000 il me semble que c'est
exactement l'inverse qui est arrivé
c'est à dire que ce qu'on nous avait
promis 30 ans à 20 avant était juste
l'inverse de ce qui s'est passé depuis
2000 le consommateur français et les
consommateurs sur la planète qui voit
l'agriculture et l'alimentation
française comme étant la plus
gastronomique du monde ont été sur les
circuits courts ont voulu des AOP ont
voulu une traçabilité des produits ont
voulu du bien manger et ont voulu sans
cesse des injonctions à l'agriculture
qui a essayé au fur et à mesure de ce
temps là de répondre à leurs exigences
et bien je vous le dis tout net sans
objectif je suis contre la viande in
vitro je ne vois pas quel est l'intérêt
pour notre culture pour notre pays
d'aller sur ces problématiques là la
première c'est que quand on nous dit le
consommateur sera informé belle sornette
comment va-t-on informer le consommateur
qui mangera un plat dans un restaurant
de la quantité qu'il aura à l'intérieur
de cette viande in vitro on nous dit il
faut plus de végétal savez-vous
mieux que nous ne produisons qu'un fruit
et un légume sur deux que nous importons
un fruit et un légume sur deux et que
nous sommes incapables par les
injonctions que nous mettons de
développer la culture de légumes et de
fruits qui devraient à vous écouter
faire la base de notre alimentation
alors est-ce que demain nous voulons
traiter le problème du carbone et
importer de plus en plus non non aussi
si ça a été dit tout à l'heure je l'ai
entendu 20% de protéines et 80% de
produits végétal
le deuxième et le troisième élément
c'est ces injonctions contradictoires
l'ultra transformée on lit sans arrêt
dans tous les journaux qu'on lutte
contre l'ultra transformé parce que ça
serait cancérigène et que l'agrobusiness
l'agro-industrie fait des produits ultra
transformés la viande in vitro n'est pas
un produit ultra transformé qu'est-ce
que c'est c'est pas un produit
totalement naturel le quatrième élément
c'est que moi je suis un amoureux des
paysages de la France on n'est pas dans
un pays qui a un désert global on a un
pays qui est multiculturel d'un point de
vue des territoires et des paysages
supprimer l'élevage en France ça serait
supprimé une très grosse partie des
paysages que nous vivons et nous aurons
véritablement des problèmes là-dessus
trois cinquième élément et j'en termine
là-dessus le savoir-faire le
savoir-faire et le patrimoine culturel
moi je le dis tout net j'ai pas envie de
vivre dans un pays où tout est aseptisé
j'ai pas envie de vivre dans un pays où
on porte un masque de l'eau à longueur
de journée je n'ai pas envie de vivre
dans un pays où on a remplacé les trois
mots de la République française de la
liberté de l'égalité et de la fraternité
par la peur la culpabilité et l'interdit
j'ai envie de vivre toujours dans un
pays libre dans lequel j'ai le droit de
manger ce que je veux et en particulier
de la viande de bovin vivant au courant
dans les prés et étant élevé par des
agriculteurs je crois que personne ici
ne tend empêchera très bien merci
Laurent nous passons à Laurent saumon
la plupart des questions étaient déjà
été posées mais je voulais revenir sur
effectivement le côté bilan énergétique
de la production d'un kilo de viande
j'allais dire une vie trop par rapport à
un kilo de viande naturel je rejoins
parfaitement je dirais ce qui a été dit
c'est que il faut pas confondre
s'alimenter ce nourrir je pense que
effectivement le plaisir de manger c'est
aussi quelque chose qui est très ancré
dans notre culture et j'ai bien retenu
l'image de ramener dans l'assiette une
histoire je pense que si on oublie ça on
oublie notre culture et aujourd'hui on
est dans une société qui veut nous faire
penser qu'il faut oublier notre culture
ou qui revisite complètement notre
culture c'était bien dommage et puis
revenir sur la question que mon confrère
collègue est néanmoins amis Arnaud Bazin
a posé sur les additifs et en
particulier la consommation
d'antibiotiques dans ce process de
fabrication et de préciser parce que
vous avez parlé que néanmoins la culture
cellulaire permettrait de développer une
filière agricole pour la constitution
des substrats
par comment vous voyez cette chose là
parce que je ne l'imagine pas et
j'aurais bien voulu avoir des précisions
à ce sujet
merci
madame le Président
merci pour pour ces éclairages bon je ne
vais pas reprendre de nombreuses choses
qui ont été dites je pense que avec
cette culture in vitro nous sommes dans
l'étape suivante de l'industrialisation
de l'agriculture très clairement et avec
une
une des études d'impact je pense qui ne
sont pas encore à la hauteur je le
prendrai simplement
trois études qui demandent à être
approfondi on l'a bien vu au niveau
environnemental il y a vraiment à voir
les impacts sur sur l'élevage qu'il
comme ça a été dit a vraiment une grande
importance dans notre culture et au
niveau de l'environnement comme plus de
carbone comme préservation de la
biodiversité comme la prévention
incendie et j'en passe donc de nombreux
impacts au niveau environnemental qu'il
faudra prendre en compte sur la santé
effectivement parler d'ultra transformé
et bien voilà c'est encore une une
marche supplémentaire
avoir avec les tous les additifs les
intrants qu'on aura dans cette viande in
vitro les hormones de croissance qui
sont quand même interdites depuis 1980
donc des impacts que l'on aura que l'on
peine à mesurer aujourd'hui on voit bien
déjà que nous sommes dans une
société où la malbouffe est très
présente et touche bien entendu les plus
précarisés qui n'ont pas forcément le
choix d'accéder à une nourriture de
qualité je pense que nous sommes la
clairement dans une nouvelle dégradation
de de la qualité et puis bien entendu ce
que reprenait monsieur monsieur Marx je
pense que là on a vraiment une rupture
en termes de culture la culture c'est un
terme polysémique
effectivement la culture avec
l'agriculture mais aussi notre culture
et là on est typiquement dans un
appauvrissement de l'humanité je pense
avec des enjeux que l'on ne pèse pas
encore aujourd'hui vraiment à leur juste
valeur donc moi aussi clairement je suis
complètement opposé à cette nouvelle
étape qui sera peut-être franchi
ailleurs alors on a toujours on en
parlait hier de la compétitivité où
doit-on passer notre compétitivité je
reviens sur ce terme là merci
merci merci Madame la présidence moi
j'ai pas de doute sur la capacité des
sociétés et de la société actuelle
d'arriver à mettre point ce type de
produit et je le dis malheureusement
j'ai pas de doute je crois que c'est une
affaire de génération et quand on voit
la facilité avec laquelle
ce type de société arrive à avoir des
levées de fonds aussi rapidement et
aussi importante je crois que vraiment
on voit bien que là et dans les pays
comme les États-Unis dans les pays je
dis pas très avancé mais dans ces pays
où la recherche est
forte on voit bien que on y va je pense
inexorablement ma question c'est porte
sur est-ce qu'on va pas avoir quelques
sociétés dans le plan de mondialisation
pas heureuse peut-être malheureuse mais
quelques sociétés qui vont tenir
l'ensemble du marché
je vois mal commun on va échapper à la
diversité de la production classique
pour aller vers des sociétés qui vont se
regrouper vont avoir une force avec du
marketing et des moyens énormes pour
imposer leur choix et sur la recherche
parce que je pense que la recherche
publique sera très vite pris de vitesse
et moi je propose plutôt à la recherche
publique de s'intéresser aux
conséquences de de l'arrivée de ces
produits sur le plan sociologique sur le
plan environnemental des changements de
métier les
impacts sur sur la nature
et puis notre débat entre agriculture
productiviste agriculture familiale
alors là vous savez on va être très vite
dépassé par des notions qui qui vont
tout faire exploser alors quand tu as
imaginé le foie gras du Périgord copié
avec des cell
je trouve que c'est la négation de la
société et comment on peut en arriver là
voilà merci
très bien Daniel Grémillet ensuite
Evelyne Renaud garabédian oui merci
Madame présidente merci aussi pour ces
quatre interventions moi je voudrais
revenir puisqu'on parle bien de la
viande in vitro sur un propos parce que
c'est une histoire à la française la
France et le pays au monde qui a su
garder la plus grande diversité animale
toute espèce confondue je le dis parce
que dans un avant d'être sénateur j'ai
présidé pendant 26 ans le comité
d'élevage au niveau national et tout ça
c'est le fruit de concours des
investissements publics et des paysans
dans tous les territoires on est le pays
au monde qui a gardé qu'à su garder la
plus grande diversité bovine bovine
Catherine porcine on peut tout prendre
on vient pas de nulle part je dis ça
parce que c'est essentiel c'est un
patrimoine génétique absolument précieux
deuxième point c'est aussi la vie qui
nous rappelle à l'ordre
la France a fait le choix du non OGM mon
propos n'est pas de dire je suis pour
les OGM mais mesurons les conséquences
c'est que nous avions de connaissance et
une capacité
d'intervention sur l'agriculture
se mentir qui a été largement appauvri
et les chercheurs ont été plutôt
outre-atlantiques que rester dans notre
pays donc on ne peut pas ne pas
s'intéresser à quelque chose qui va se
passer à travers le monde je pense que
c'est essentiel et je remercie la
présidente de mettre ça à l'ordre du
jour parce qu'effectivement on est un
peu avant-gardiste mais tout va très
vite
dans un passé aussi j'étais syndicaliste
à l'époque quand nos est parlé de lève
végétale il ne restait pas dans les
rayons plus de 24 heures
le lait de soja je vous rappelle
l'histoire j'y ai participé comme
d'autres
et aujourd'hui si vous êtes allé au ciel
en 2022
y compris des entreprises françaises
sans aucun problème mettre et vente des
produits
issus de production le protéines
végétales purement végétal sont original
pourquoi je dis ça c'est pour vous dire
en l'espace de 20 ans quelque chose qui
n'était pas accepté même là les paysans
sans problème l'acceptent donc ça serait
une erreur que la France ne s'intéresse
pas effectivement à cette aspect des
choses en termes de recherche des mots
je souhaiterais vraiment
je souhaite vraiment qu'on est une
expertise scientifique très poussée
parce qu'elle est essentielle elle est
doit être indépendante du travail et de
recherche qui est fait au niveau des
entreprises c'est ces deux éléments qui
doivent être complémentaires et qui
devraient ensuite pour nous au niveau
politique être des éléments à la
décision je dis ça parce que on voit
bien qu'on est au carrefour
l'autre point que je voulais évoquer et
c'est une question
c'est l'aspect sanitaire on sait tous la
dangereuse dangerosité effectivement et
notre vétérinaire l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure mais vous aussi pour le vivre
dans des toutes productions alimentaires
est une matière vivante et dès lors
qu'on a une concentration importante je
vous passe des conflits qui pourraient
effectivement mettre en situation de
péril des unités de production
donc on concentre le risque
d'alimentation sur un point lorsqu'on a
un élevage le risque est dispersé et sur
la spécialité c'est la même chose il y a
un aspect aussi important qu'il est je
souhaiterais de voir comment il a été
analysé parce qu'effectivement c'est un
point et mes deux dernières remarques
dans l'alimentation je prends l'exemple
de l'alimentation porcine c'est pas
quand même très vieux où on a interdit
toute présence d'antibiotiques dans
l'aliment qui était distribué aux portes
tous les jours avant pour qu'on protège
l'animal systématiquement il y avait des
antibiots donc ma question et ça rejoint
ce qui était évoqué tout à l'heure
est-ce que le risque sanitaire ne
nécessite pas là aussi une présence de
de protection de ces cellules souches
qu'on va alimenter et ma dernière
remarque
c'est sur l'honnêteté
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand le veuille ou
non la France et l'Europe a interdit des
OGM et vous en mangez tous les jours
tous les jours parce que dans les
produits dans les ingrédients qui sont
importés et bien il y a d'autres pays et
ils vous les avez tous les jours et le
sujet je remercie notre chef
effectivement de son propos parce que ça
fait partie de l'histoire française et
nous en sommes aussi des héritiers mais
nous devrons aussi le transmettre et
effectivement comment pouvons-nous
protéger cette histoire française
tel qu'on le voit aujourd'hui entre ce
que l'on aurait envie et de en fait ce
qui va effectivement être dans
l'assiette qui est complètement
contraire et en opposition avec nos
envies
merci Daniel Evelyne Renaud garabéeian
et ensuite Fabien on va y arriver merci
moi je me place en tant que consommateur
et je ne porte pas de jugement ni sur la
technique ou sur d'autres aspects je
vous avoue qu'en tant que consommateur
et en tant que sénateur des Français de
l'étranger je suis un petit peu
sceptique sur tout ce que j'ai entendu
et je voudrais poser une question à
Monsieur Marx parce que d'abord
premièrement je pense que c'est pas un
problème de générationnel moi je sais
que j'en consommerai pas il y en a
d'autres qui n'en consommeraient pas
quel que soit la génération faut pas
penser non plus que les gens âgés vont
pas en consommer que les autres vont
consommer mais ça c'est mon avis
personnel moi je voudrais poser une
question à tirer max pour savoir s'il
est prêt demain à mettre dans à partir
du moment on aura l'homologation en
France est-ce qu'il émette est d'accord
pour mettre demain dans l'un de ces
restaurants un plat dans lequel il y
aura de la viande in vitro et je
m'interroge aussi sur l'image que la
gastronomie française pourrait avoir à
l'étranger à partir du moment où la
France est l'excellence de la France a
été reconnu dans la gastronomie pour
aussi bien la qualité des produits que
le service à l'assiette que nous avons
donc j'aimerais que vous puissiez vous
répondre sur ce sujet là
merci
en tout cas de cette matinée parce que
j'en prends beaucoup de choses
on a mis le rendu plomb et donc un wok
kyste puisqu'il pour le
multicultéralisme des paysages et
j'apprends que Daniel a été à la CGT
donc
rien que pour ça je suis content de
mettre levé ce matin et d'avoir fait une
heure et demie de RER bon plus
sérieusement
je sais pas si c'est un enjeu de
génération je crois pas je partage
plutôt ce que je viens de dire ma
collègue
vous avez vu il y a une opposition
plutôt totale
quel que soit notre couleur politique et
je crois qu'elle dit quelque chose sur
la société dans laquelle on vit et dans
laquelle on veut vivre voilà je dis ça
parce que
moi je suis pareil c'est pas mon truc
vous l'aurez compris je pense que
l'alimentation est une vraie question
le plaisir de la table aussi je pense
qu'il faut aussi en parler et ça se voit
d'ailleurs
j'ai plaisir je pense que la question
l'alimentation pour toutes et tous aussi
est une question vous savez j'habite en
Seine-Saint-Denis et je pense que tout
le monde a droit au bon mais tout le
monde peut pas se le payer aujourd'hui
et une des questions
alors peut-être que vous arriverez à y
répondre c'est que nous allons continuer
à aller vers 10 milliards d'êtres
humains sur la planète et est-ce qu'au
final tout le monde pourra se nourrir et
dans des bonnes conditions aujourd'hui
c'est déjà pas le cas mais est-ce que
c'est votre solution
en tout cas moi c'est peut-être vous y
arriverez parce que vous allez avoir du
financement et on y reviendra d'ailleurs
dis-moi qui te finance on me dira qui
qui tu es quand même il y a une question
autour de ça mais s'il y a tant de
milliards qui sont levés partout dans le
monde sur cette question c'est que le
capital a bien compris que une des
parties pouvait jouer là donc peut-être
qu'on sera tous des idiots dans 10 ans
ou 15 ans qu'on regardera cette audition
mais c'est pas grave et donc moi je
crois d'abord que l'enjeu on doit se le
poser en termes d'alimentation
d'agriculture je sais plus je crois que
c'est Laurent qui le disait mais quand
même et a juste raison
dans un moment où on a des traités de
libre-échange que nous on refuse on peut
avoir le débat parce qu'on se dit que on
est en train de tuer nos agriculteurs
ici et qu'on accepte au moins 10 ans
social et environnementales des produits
qui font 4 fois le tour de la planète
puis là on est en train de nous vendre
un truc bourré aux antibiotiques et au
fongicides bon voilà
est-ce qu'on continue comme ça en tout
cas c'est pas la société dans laquelle
j'ai envie de vivre bon donc je suis en
réflexion je dis pas que voilà il faut
refuser et je partage une question par
contre je pense que la recherche
publique doit y aller à fond
ça oui parce qu'à un moment donné
autrement on aura dû décrochage et de
toute façon parce que vous y êtes et
parce que d'autres ils sont dans 10 ans
ça sera un marché et donc si on pouvait
éviter une nouvelle fois d'être à la
traîne ça nous arrangerait donc il faut
qu'il y ait de la recherche publique
qu'on y aille mais en tout cas voilà je
pense que ça nous interroge bien au-delà
sur notre bien manger notre culture
agriculture notre alimentation notre
façon de voir la société et pour
l'instant c'est pas c'est pas celle dans
laquelle j'ai envie de vivre mais bon
peut-être que dans 20 ans j'aurai tort
et pour terminer Patricia je suis nager
merci beaucoup il y a quelques années un
français s'est exporté comme on dit
étaler en Israël et à
fonder voilà merci une une un
laboratoire avec Alf farm donc c'était
un des
premiers à créer donc le steak quelques
grammes qui coûtait 50 dollars et je
voulais je m'interroger sur le niveau
comment on était compétitif en France
par rapport à d'autres pays parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la recherche c'est
pas demain qu'on va manger un steak à 50
g et surtout seulement quelques grammes
50 dollars à quelques grammes vous
voulez savoir comment faire pour garder
aussi nos chercheurs parce que c'est
important comment est-ce que parce qu'en
France on a un savoir-faire on sait à
l'INRA comment est-ce que justement
dans le futur on pourra aussi avoir
nos inventions entre guillemets et je
sais très bien moi je pense que ce sera
pas demain pour mangera ce style de
nourriture mais on est en plein dans la
dans la recherche donc avoir un peu
votre retour au niveau français au
niveau européen et puis au niveau
mondial merci merci juste pour terminer
cette série de questions moi en fait
dans les propos que j'ai entendu se
posent souvent la question du marché en
fait du marché économique du marché qui
sous-tend et du coup ma question elle
est là c'est quoi vos prévisions en fait
dans le monde dans en France avec série
de réticence qu'on entend ici sur les
conséquences sur l'élevage sur le
conséquences sur la gastronomie sur le
plaisir de manger sur quelquefois
l'opposition alimentation et nutrition
mais vous puisque vous êtes des startups
je me tourne vers vous votre marché
parce que vous allez sortir un jour de
ce cette ce statut de startup pour être
dans la dans la vraie vie économique
c'est quoi votre marché j'ai entendu
vous étiez en train de monter une usine
donc voilà en France c'est quoi votre
marché
impatiente
il y a tellement de questions je compte
aussi sur Nicolas à côté de moi pour
pour se relier pour essayer d'y répondre
ça va être difficile de les de les de
les prendre dans l'ordre je rebondi déjà
sur sur un élément important je pense
que ça a été posé parmi plusieurs
interventions la bonne perspective pour
se poser les bonnes questions
aujourd'hui sur la viande de culture
c'est qu'est-ce que sera notre monde
notre marché français et le marché
international dans 10 ou 15 ans c'est
faut vraiment qu'on s'extrait
aujourd'hui où on est encore en face de
recherche ou ces produits sont
complètement nouveaux peu connus etc et
où on a des des réticences qui sont
naturelles et se projeter sur dans 10-15
ans quand on sera dans un monde où
l'adaptation réchauffement climatique
deviendra quelque chose de extrêmement
concret sur nos systèmes de production
agricole où on le voit des pandémices
développent dans nos élevages comment on
va faire face à ça donc le contexte sera
très différent donc il faut beaucoup
d'ouverture aussi imaginez que le monde
sera très différent dans 10 ou 15 ans de
ce qu'il est de ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
voilà élément élément de contexte qui
est rejoint pas mal de choses je peux
pas tout détailler le plaisir de la
table on n'a pas renoncé du tout au
plaisir de la table et Nicolas à côté on
a un exemple avec son foie gras de
culture et nous nos produits seront
d'abord bon ce que de toute façon les
consommateurs n'en mangeront pas si ce
n'est pas bon et on n'a pas non plus
renoncé au plaisir de la table et là
aussi je veux voilà casser une idée
reçue qui ressort une sorte d'opposition
entre l'élevage et ce qu'on est en train
de faire on n'est pas en train de dire
qu'il faut manger de la viande de
culture seulement de la viande de
culture et à la place de l'élevage la
viande de culture c'est une
diversification des sources de protéines
moi je mange je suis très attaché au
territoire très attaché au terroir etc
maintenant très honnêtement quand je
prends une salade César en 20 minutes
devant mon ordinateur le côté
gastronomique et territoires et moins
présent que quand je mange un poulet
rôti le dimanche midi auprès de ma
famille et c'est déjà le cas et
l'idée n'est pas du tout de renoncer à
ça et pareil sur l'opposition entre
l'élevage et nous ce qu'on propose quand
je mange un plat de lentilles je ne suis
pas en train de m'opposer à l'élevage je
ne suis pas en train de dire non à
l'élevage donc là on est une source de
protéines nouvelle etc je donc voilà
pareil sur le les produits ultra
transformés donc cultive des cellules
notre produit à la fin c'est des
cellules il y a pas de transformation
particulière je veux dire nos modes de
production pour faire très simple parce
que ça peut être dit c'est une grande
cuve avec le milieu nutritif et les
cellules intérieures et à la fin on
sépare les cellules du milieu nutritif
on les on les lave pour qu'il n'y ait
plus rien lié au milieu nutritif qui
soit dans les cellules et donc
finalement c'est un procédé qui est très
proche de la production d'une levure une
levure n'est pas un produit transformé
après ça dépend quel produit final on va
faire avec la levure donc le produit en
tant que tel n'est pas un produit
transformé mais peut-être en priorité
répondent sur la question sanitaire
qui est une et la question de santé
publique et une question centrale
évidemment pour nos nouveaux produits
d'abord rappeler que nous ne mettons pas
d'hormones de croissance au sens où on
en a connu dans l'élevage avec des
bovins sous stéroïdes etc il y a des
subtilités scientifiques bref ce qui
peut se retrouver et ça dépend encore là
encore des technologies dans les milieux
de culture ce sont des facteurs de
croissance des petites protéines qui
seront éliminées à la fin avec le milieu
de culture donc on n'est pas du tout sur
le même sujet et il ne faut pas du tout
faire d'amalgame entre le bœuf sous
hormones sous stéroïdes et certains
facteurs de croissance qui peuvent se
retrouver dans certains milieux de
culture et il est important de rappeler
que nos produits ont parlé du principe
de précaution seront soumis à une
autorisation préalable de l'ESSA
européen foot SAFTI agency qui est
peut-être la meilleure agence de
sécurité alimentaire dans le monde selon
un processus long avec un dossier
complexe
pour un processus qui va durer au minima
18 mois et où toutes les questions
seront posées avec les meilleurs
spécialistes du monde sur ces sujets là
donc évidemment que les produits qui
arriveront sur le marché français demain
seront des produits dont la sécurité
alimentaire sera garantie et évidemment
l'impact positif aussi sur la nutrition
plus globalement
au travers de ces aspects sanitaires il
y avait également la question des
antibiotiques qui étaient posées
effectivement l'élevage au niveau
mondial c'est plus de 50% de la
consommation des antibiotiques
qu'on consomme en une année évidemment
ça participe à l'antibiorésistance qui
devient un sujet de plus en plus
préoccupant et on en est tous conscients
d'où l'intérêt de développer des
nouveaux modes de production comme
l'agriculture cellulaire où on peut
produire sans utilisation
d'antibiotiques car on est en
environnement contrôlé et dans des
conditions sanitaires extrêmement
irréprochable qui nous permet de voir de
produire sans antibiotiques
[Musique]
oui pour compléter un petit peu je pense
que si on catégorise les deux les deux
remarques qu'on a retrouvé dans beaucoup
de questions il y avait la dimension
culturelle et la dimension des
interrogations et des doutes qui
persistaient cela dimension culturelle
le plaisir de manger la dimension
traditionnelle l'histoire il faut quand
même replacer ça dans le contexte
justement de l'innovation culinaire la
cuisine n'a cessé de se réinventer
l'agriculture n'a cessé de se réinventer
donc pourquoi est-ce que l'agriculture
cellulaire la viande de culture ne
s'intègre pas dans cette histoire et ne
ferait pas partie d'un des chapitres de
cette histoire pas le nouveau chapitre
pas le chapitre ultime du tout mais un
des chapitres en parallèle de tout un
tas d'innovations qui sont aujourd'hui
qui concourent à répondre aux nouvelles
demandes de de citoyens et de notre
société notre société s'appelle gourmet
c'est pour une raison simple c'est qu'on
a mis le goût au cœur de notre démarche
donc tous nos produits ils sont
développés qu'aux développés avec des
experts du monde de la cuisine avec des
chefs avec des restaurateurs qui
soutiennent ces produits là et qui
justement ont continuellement apporté un
éclairage sur le développement de notre
produit et notamment sur notre
alternative au foie là si on a une fois
la culture dans la mission numéro une
est d'apporter aussi un niveau de
plaisir et évidemment de ne pas
représenter une forme de concession sans
pour autant copier évidemment le foie de
la traditionnel auquel nous sommes tous
s'attacher moi le premier mon associé et
tellement également originaire du
sud-ouest ça évidemment créer des
discussions familiales intenses de son
côté quand il s'engageait dans ce projet
là mais un petit peu comme les membres
de la commission et Monsieur Ritman au
premier plan au final le niveau
d'information et de connaissance du
sujet amène quelque part une plus grande
ouverture on est consciente c'est un
sujet qui a une dimension quelque part
spectaculaire quelque part étonnante au
premier abord et qui génère des idées
peut-être trop rapidement rigide sur ce
sujet là on est là justement pour
répondre à vos questions et pour faire
toute la lumière sur ce procédé là qui
comme le disait Étienne Dutoit
ressemblera quelque part à l'échelle de
production à une brasserie dans laquelle
on produit de la bière il faut imaginer
des fermenteurs en inox des cuves en
inox dans lesquelles les cellules seront
alimentées au même titre que des levures
qui donnent de la bière donc cette
analogie elle permet juste de se figurer
un environnement qui n'est pas encore
sur pied mais qui déjà peut-être permet
une forme de familiarité qui manque
aujourd'hui cruellement à ce sujet là et
encore une fois c'est l'objet de notre
présence la deuxième chose sur la
dimension culture et plaisir justement
la méthode de production de la viande de
culture est une méthode de production on
pourrait la faire de mille façons il y
aura des sociétés qui la feront d'une
façon x donne une façon y les sociétés
américaines à leur façon c'est
l'opportunité pour la France de la faire
de le faire quelque part à la française
avec des objectifs et des standards sur
le goût extrêmement élevé des objectifs
de sourcing sur le substrat également
l'alimentation des cellules extrêmement
élevées et sur l'impact environnemental
parce que là aussi et c'est une question
qui est revenue et que j'aimerais
compléter la question du bilan
environnemental est central pour poser
les choses deux sources d'impact
environnemental sur la viande de culture
l'énergie utilisée donc comment est-ce
qu'on va chauffer les bioréacteurs les
fermenteurs et de deux comment est-ce
qu'on va alimenter les cellules donc
pour poser le sujet c'est assez simple
en fonction de nos choix technologiques
en matière d'approvisionnement sur ces
deux sujets là le bilan peut être plus
ou moins favorable au même titre que
pour l'élevage comment est-ce qu'on va
nourrir nos animaux avec des substrats
qui ont nécessité beaucoup d'engrais
azoter ou non
encore ce même type de choix se
présentera pour les acteurs de
l'agriculture cellulaire et nous on
s'engage en tant que société française
qui souhaite rester en France à faire
les choix les plus vertueux et les plus
profitables à l'écosystème agricole
français auquel on s'intègre
il est un peu trop tôt pour tirer des
conclusions sur l'impact
environnementale et ça je pense que
c'est hyper important aujourd'hui et je
suis vraiment d'accord avec toutes les
conclusions qu'on a vu à droite ou à
gauche dans cette mission il faut
investir dans la recherche notamment sur
cette partie là l'année prochaine notre
premier point de production sera
construit sera en production et on
s'engage à justement à fournir ce qu'on
appelle des analyses dans cycle de vie
qui feront la lumière de façon très
factuelle sur l'impact environnemental
et ce sera le cas à tous les stades de
production
gardons juste en tête que c'est une
industrie naissante on ne peut pas
mettre toutes les attentes au niveau le
plus élevé sur cette industrie descente
les choses iront étape par étape et la
vertu de ce procédé de production ira en
s'améliorant à mesure qu'on apprendra à
faire les choses de manière plus frugale
de manière plus économe de manière plus
locale enfin sur le côté sanitaire on a
parlé du principe de précaution pour
compléter ce que disait Étienne Dutoit
le processus de mise sur le marché qu'on
appelle novel food de nouveaux aliments
en Europe et déjà une application de ce
principe de précaution puisque ce sont
des temps très longs de deux à trois ans
de mise sur le marché ou toute une série
de tests sur à la fois tous les intrants
qui prendront pas au substrat et la fois
tous les résidus éventuels toute la
qualité nutritionnelle du produit fini
sera investiguée et scruté de manière
extrêmement approfondie les produits de
la viande de culture sont parmi les
produits les plus scrutés les plus
analysés pour en garantir justement
l'innocuité et comme Monsieur Dutoit
nous n'utilisons aucun antibiotique et
nous n'utilisons pas d'hormones de
croissance ça c'est quand même assez
important de le préciser on peut faire
sans et justement peut-être le faire à
la française c'est le faire de cette
façon et en tout cas c'est comme ça que
chez gourmet nous le faisons
n'hésite pas à préciser si tu souhaites
non j'étais plus sur effectivement
rebondir sur sur cet aspect viande de
culture à la française et je pense que
c'est vraiment le point fondamental
qu'on doit qu'on doit qu'on doit
proposer aujourd'hui et ça rebondit sur
une autre thématique qui a été évoquée
celle des mastodontes de la viande etc
est-ce qu'il y a pas un risque de
concentration etc
ma réponse elle est claire les macédons
de la viande ils existent déjà aux
États-Unis etc dans des systèmes
économiques tels que les États-Unis il
est probable qu'il reproduisent ce
qu'ils connaissent déjà ici en France ma
conviction c'est que ça va être
différent de ce point de vue là voilà
moi je voulais dire je suis monté par le
groupe Remo qui est une ti qui est
complètement intégré dans notre système
agricole aujourd'hui moi ma Vocation
c'est d'être producteur d'un ingrédient
du poulet cultivé et je discute avec les
systèmes coopératifs avec les boîtes
agroalimentaires qui
sont dans nos territoires que vous
connaissez tous pour faire des produits
finaux des plats cuisinés en utilisant
mon ingrédient donc on s'intègre
complètement dans une filière
agroalimentaire existante et dans un
système économique diversifié comme il
l'est aujourd'hui de même sur la sur le
l'approvisionnement des nutriments on
travaille avec un producteur de milieu
de culture française et voilà et donc il
y a une possibilité de créer une filière
française une filière à la française
avec les acteurs actuels de
l'agroalimentaire qui seront partis
prenantes de ce système là
laissez la parole voilà au directeur de
recherche
merci j'aurais cinq points de réaction à
un point concernant les antibiotiques
j'ai lu une publication internationale
écrite par différentes entreprises
certes pas françaises mais qui disait
quand même que
l'utilisation d'antibiotiques était
possible ou probable probablement à des
niveaux inférieurs comparativement à
l'élevage mais que
l'exclusion totale des antibiotiques
c'est pas si évident que ça
un deuxième point concernant la
communication je suis tout à fait
d'accord qu'il faut évidemment
communiquer et expliquer le processus de
fabrication mais je suis moins d'accord
avec l'idée que expliquer le processus
de fabriquer à Sion entraîne forcément
une meilleure acceptation c'est pas du
tout évident
selon la façon dont on présente les
choses etc etc et évidemment ça m'amène
à plaider une nouvelle fois pour les
questions de transparence
et si vous avez effectivement une unité
de production
je serai ravi si vous pouviez
communiquer non seulement les analyses
de cycle de vie mais également les
données brutes qui ont servi à ces
analyses de cycle de vie dans une
politique de sciences ouvertes qui est
mise en avant aujourd'hui par la
Communauté européenne
encore deux petits points très
importants
évidemment cette problématique doit être
abordée dans toutes ces dimensions non
seulement techniques mais aussi
environnementales culturel social etc
etc et dans un organisme de recherche
comme inrae qui comprend au total 12000
personnes il y a 14 départements de
recherche plus ou moins enfin orienté
soit sur les aspects techniques soit sur
les aspects d'alimentation humaine soit
sur les aspects de sciences sociales et
on a la capacité de conduire ce qu'on
appelle une expertise collective et j'en
arrive au dernier point
sur commande du ministère de
l'agriculture ou sur commande des élus
que vous êtes notre institution peut se
saisir effectivement d'un dossier
d'expertise collective pour analyser la
dimension toutes les dimensions de cette
problématique mais pour l'instant ça n'a
pas été le cas donc pour l'instant
quelques recherches quelques chercheurs
comme moi s'intéressent à cette question
mais l'institution n'a pas été saisie du
demande formelle soit du gouvernement
soit des élus de d'avoir une expertise
collective dans toutes ces dimensions en
mobilisant tous les experts dans les
différents domaines que j'ai cités
je vous remercie très bien on va laisser
conclure par Monsieur Marx et d'avance
je vous remercie voilà de ces débats de
ces questions qui sont qui ne sont qu'au
début
merci merci de me laisser conclure je
suis
touché de le faire alors je vais essayer
de le faire de façon bicéphale soit je
réponds de façon
appartenant à la chair universitaire
Paris Saclay sur la cuisine du futur et
l'alimentation du futur et dans ce cas
là je me dis bah continue observer
cherchons il y a pas de raison que la
France soit à la traîne là-dessus si je
réponds en tant qu'artisan artisan
cuisinier lié à la gastronomie je
réponds quand même assez attriste de
façon assez simple oui non je pardon je
n'en mettrai pas à ma carte
mais je vais le faire je ne pourrais pas
empêcher que ce produit existe je vais
répondre pourquoi je le mettrai pas à ma
carte parce que je vais servir dans
cette gastronomie que des ultras
possédants que des ultras riches
parce que on aura protégé ça je crois
pas qu'on puisse
le faire disparaître on va protéger les
petits élevages les petits faiseurs les
les petits producteurs seront
extrêmement protégés parce que pourront
vendre leurs prix par au prix mais à la
valeur et puis on va continuer et ça va
exister cette ce qu'on appelle cette
viande et tous les éléments de langage
sont là gourmets France origine france
garantissent sanitaire et là on va
continuer et je vous fiche mon billet
quand on commence à lever des sommes
comme 60 millions de dollars ou d'euros
peu importe 100 millions on voit bien
que c'est pour qui c'est pour répondre à
cette alimentation à deux vitesses
vous avez une alimentation pour les gens
qui vont bien
qui peuvent payer qu'on va rester à
vivre suffisant et une alimentation
depuis les années 70 pour les gens qui
vont pas bien et qui en reste à vivre
très faible donc l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui est un darwinisme
pur s'adapte il faut faire moins de
viande il faut être plus
environnementale donc on vous sort tous
les mots d'impact environnemental et on
vous dit ça va être merveilleux on va
faire des pots de prix en l'occurrence
renoncer à la qualité et on vous fera à
manger à moindre coût vous avez renoncé
à la qualité alors on vous fait un dépit
pris c'est encore la théorie du low cost
avec les mêmes éléments de langage que
nous avons dû à partir des années 70
renoncer à la qualité on vous fait des
petits prix et aujourd'hui l'industrie
s'était emparée de ça la grande
distribution s'est emparée de ça et puis
on y met évidemment des forces comme
vous l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur de
marketing extrêmement forte extrêmement
puissante mais ce type de projet et
encore une fois si je me range en tant
que chercheur là ça m'intéresse je me
dis oui allons voir il y a pas de raison
que la France soit à la traîne de ça
mais de toute façon à un moment donné on
ne pilotera plus on pourra ça sera comme
les OGM on va se dire non non c'est à
nos frontières mais non et ce qui
m'inquiète c'est la perte de culture et
la manipulation des masses sur
l'alimentation plus vous allez appauvrir
les masses en termes de culture moins
elle connaîtront ce qu'elles ont à
manger plus vous les manipulerez donc
c'est une perte d'identité
d'identité locale d'identité nationale
pour rentrer vers une alimentation
mondialisée et normalisée je peux me
tromper mais par expérience ce que
j'apprends avec les chercheurs de Paris
Saclay et tu dis d'abord le passé pour
voir le présent et entrevoir l'avenir
mais le passé m'apprend que l'argent
l'argent et ce côté
très darwiniste du monde capitaliste
disons-le et bien s'adapte et
aujourd'hui il faut faire une industrie
agroalimentaire avec de la viande
ultra transformée et bien et on y mettra
les éléments de langage qu'il faut je
trouve que personnellement je peux me
tromper je peux être le has been de
service mais c'est une boîte de Pandore
et on a plutôt intérêt à essayer de
contenir un peu cette boîte de Pandore
mais quand on voit évidemment les sommes
qui sont levées et quand j'entends d'une
représentation de l'état de toute façon
l'Europe décidera il va être très
difficile d'expliquer à aux gens que
nous fréquentons au quotidien que
l'Europe peut décider du contenu de mon
assiette parce que ils ont la puissance
de l'argent
c'est dérangeant c'est une perte
d'identité nationale qui moi
personnellement me dérange alors pour
répondre à la sénatrice non je n'en
servirai pas je n'aurais pas à le faire
parce que la gastronomie française va
devenir une toute petite gastronomie
réservée au plus initiés mais pour
initier les gens à la gastronomie il
faut commencer à l'école et de commencer
entrevoir le mangeur de demain donc moi
je milite aujourd'hui pour comprendre ce
qu'on mange pour refaire le mangeur
plutôt que le consommateur et le
surconsommateur ça c'est ça me paraît
une démarche pour moi qui est
essentielle de se dire et bah oui
regardons maîtrisons parce que la
recherche française doit continuer à
maîtriser ça mais le risque c'est et
vous le savez comme moi ça va nous
échapper comme notre agriculture vous
voyez déjà et je termine mon propos
n'oublions pas et on a parté on a parlé
d'agroécologie et avec le système pardon
bleu Blanco nous avons défini ce qui
était un bon produit
son impact social son impact
environnemental et son impact
nutritionnel ça ça a du sens pour moi et
on voit bien que le monde agricole
contre le reconsidée en tant que paysan
mais pas comme simplement fournisseur de
minerai il redevient paysan il a des
économies beaucoup plus symbiotiques et
beaucoup plus proche et finalement il
devient acteur d'une France qui est
capable de produire de bons produits
pour tous moi ce qui m'intéresse avec ce
type d'action comme bloboker c'est
d'être aussi bien à la Grande Épicerie
de Paris où on sait que c'est quand même
pas le plus abordable mais aussi dans la
grande distribution de permettent à des
personnes d'avoir accès à un bon produit
merci très bien merci beaucoup on n'aura
pas encore réconcilié toutes les choses
mais on aura pris beaucoup
d'informations merci infiniment d'avoir
participé merci beaucoup à vous merci
je suis pas sûr qu'on soit au bout de la
réflexion mais c'est le début de la
réflexion c'est intéressant voilà merci
beaucoup je vous propose chers collègues
qu'on fasse